in the early 70s I went to New York with  great ambition didn't know a person like  eight nine million people and me and I  want you to be an actor and let me just  tell you that was a bomb out it was not  pretty so rather than completely go back  and maybe drive a forklift somewhere I  said okay you know I really do love the  film business I love stories I love  telling stories I'm not that good at it  at least I had never approve of myself  and I started to write and I were going  to movie theaters with a really cheesy  tape recorder I record the dialogue and  then I would try to write different  dialogue not that I succeeded but it's  the effort to count but it's loaded but  surely I thought wow each screenplay is  getting better the first five you  wouldn't line your bird cage with it  nope you wouldn't train your puppy on it  nope but around the fifth and sixth one  ah not bad and if I had never done that  I would be talking to you today